Unidad ciudadana Chile contra los abusos.
Voy a votar en contra de la nueva constitución
porque le garantiza ganancias multimillonarias
a las AFP, quienes se han enriquecido
con las cotizaciones previsionales
de los chilenos chilenas.
Creo que es un texto que se conceptualizó dividiendo,
polarizando y segregando a la gente de nuestro país.
Disfrazar de deportes criollos,
el maltrato animal propio del rodeo,
de las carreras de galgo,
de la carrera la chilena, incluso de las peleas de gallo,
es una bajeza.
Votamos en contra por la cultura,
por el derecho fundamental
de ejercer y desarrollar la cultura
en este territorio.
Votamos en contra,
por eso voy a votar en contra.
Voto rechazo. Por eso voto en contra.
Voy a votar en contra
unidad ciudadana Chile, contra los abusos.
Voto en contra
porque esta constitución
es una constitución que nos hace retroceder a nosotras
las mujeres. Pero sobre todo voto en contra
porque es una constitución sin ética.
Una constitución busca distribuir el poder
y esta propuesta,
la verdad, lo que hace
es fijarla en la elite política y económica.
Esta nueva propuesta constitución no me representa
puesto que niega el cambio climático
y esto afecta a todos los seres vivos y al futuro.
Voy a estar en contra
porque esta nueva constitución nos encasilla,
no fue representativa y además
no refleja la pluralidad de nuestro país.
Votamos en contra,
vota en contra, por eso voy a votar en contra.
Yo voto en contra